[Música]
tudo o que eu vou falar em resultado da
minha pesquisa com 1.700 homens e
mulheres de mais de 60 mais de 70 mais
de 80 anos
atualmente estou pesquisando ag aqueles
que têm mais de 90 anos
a minha maior inspiração para falar
sobre a invenção de uma bela velhice
foi o livro a velhice de semana de bobô
a semana de broward ceeac velha sempre o
outro pois as pessoas de mais idade não
se enxergam como velhas mas ela alertava
velho não é o outro cada um de nós
deveria ser reconhecer no velho que é
hoje o novo velho que será amanhã velho
não é o outro velho sou eu
simone boa'
após descrever o dramático quadro do
processo de envelhecimento apontou
possível caminho para invenção de uma
bela velhice ter um projeto de vida
a obra do psiquiatra victor frankl é uma
referência fundamental para entender a
importância do projeto de vida na
invenção de uma bela velhice
frank foi prisioneiro de 1942 a 1945 em
quatro campos de concentração
seu pai sua mãe seu irmão e sua esposa
grávida foram assassinados pelos
nazistas ele se perguntava por que eu
consegui sobreviver ea resposta que ele
encontrou foi porque eu tinha um projeto
de vida
seu projeto era escrever sobre essa
dramática experiência no campo de
concentração e criar uma terapia baseada
no holocausto que ajudasse todas as
pessoas a encontrar o sentido das suas
vidas
no amor no trabalho ou até mesmo no
sofrimento
frank escreveu para espanto de muitos
que nos campos de concentração havia
humor ele acreditava que o humor era uma
arma poderosa na luta pela sobrevivência
por isso ele combinou com um amigo do
campo de concentração inventam é piada
por dia para se distanciar do sofrimento
inevitável
frank morreu em 1997 aos 92 anos e
provou que ter projetos de vida e dar
muitas risadas
são armas poderosas para a invenção de
uma bela velhice
após assistir cinco vezes o mesmo show
de paul mccartney
eu perguntei para um amigo meu de 77
anos porque ele aos 75 anos faz um show
de três horas cantando e tocando e
dançando sem parar
se o público ficaria feliz com show de
apenas uma hora
meu amigo me respondeu sorrindo porque
ele tem muito tesão no que ele faz para
chamar por marcar também de velho dá pra
chamar chico caetano gil bethânia
marieta severo que tá ali
fernanda montenegro nem mato grosso de
velhos
eles são exemplos de uma geração e dylan
sem idade inclassificável uma geração
que revolucionou os comportamentos na
década de 60 nos continuam cantando
amando dançando trabalhando que
ando transgredindo tabus
eles não se aposentaram de si mesmos
eles não se tornaram invisíveis mas não
precisa ser uma celebridade para
inventar uma bela venice que aprendi com
os meus pesquisados de mais 90 anos as
mulheres falaram muito mais sobre os
seus medos desejos e sofrimentos
relacionadas à velhice
as mulheres brasileiras especialmente as
mais jovens tem pânico de envelhecer
os homens falaram muito pouco do medo da
velhice na bela vê ele se eles querem
continuar sendo úteis ativos e
produtivos
mas eles não querem trabalhar apenas por
obrigação pra ganhar dinheiro eles
querem ter tesão no que lhes faz o lema
por uma bela violência poderia ser eu
não preciso mais
mas eu quero os homens também querem ter
mais tempo pra curtir a casa a família a
esposa os filhos e os netos
eles querem ter tempo para esse mundo do
afeto que eles não puderam aproveitar
quando eram mais jovens estão
preocupados em ganhar dinheiro para
sustentar a família
já as mulheres falaram de liberdade
quando eu perguntei para as mulheres
mais jovens porque elas mais inveja nos
homens
elas disseram em primeiríssimo lugar
liberdade em segundo lugar elas disseram
fazer xixi em pé
quando eu perguntei para os homens o que
eles mais inveja nas mulheres
eles responderão simplesmente nada mas
as mulheres mais velhas que eu pesquisei
disseram categoricamente este é o melhor
momento da minha vida nunca fui tão
feliz
é a primeira vez que eu posso ser eu
mesma nunca foi tão livre e como elas
conquistaram a liberdade tão desejada
primeiro lugar elas fizeram uma
verdadeira faxina existencial
a faxina não é só joga fora a roupa que
não serve mais os cacarecos as coisas
inúteis e são mais fácil a faxina
existencial é tirar das nossas vidas
todas aquelas pessoas que nos fazem mal
só criticam sugam a nossa energia
os verdadeiros vampiros emocionais
em segundo lugar elas falaram muito da
importância das amigas na bela velhice
são as amigas que cuidam que convençam
que escutam que levam ao médico que lhe
foram todos os dias para saber como elas
estão as mulheres falaram muito mais das
amigas do que dos maridos dos filhos e
até dos netos
as amigas são a família escolhida em
terceiro lugar
elas falaram da importância de dizer não
às mulheres mais jovens têm muita
dificuldade para dizer não
elas querem agradar a todo mundo que me
cuidar de todo mundo reclama que não tem
tempo pra elas mais velhas
elas aprendem a dizer não agora eu vou
gravar em primeiro lugar mim mesma vou
cuidar de mim o tempo é pra mim essa
mudança
de foco é uma verdadeira revolução
elas também disseram as minhas
pesquisadas está não sou eu falando que
elas aprenderam a ligar o botão do forró
da se naquelas ficam dizendo pra
todo mundo foi desse peso também não é
isso é um se interior vão achar que
eu sou uma velha ridícula porque eu vou
à praia de biquíni
vou achar que eu sou uma velha sem noção
porque eu gosto de dar beijo na boca
acha que eu sou uma velha baranga porque
eu ainda uso minissaia e se se
interior é libertador experimenta por
último
elas disseram que aprender a rir e
brincar muito mais 60% das mulheres mais
jovens que eu pesquisei disseram que
inveja capacidade masculina de rio de
qualquer bobagem
elas querem ia ser mais leves brincar
mais
ontem então que fez no rio eu não tenho
tempo
eu tenho medo da opinião dos outros mais
velhas elas aprendem a brincar e ria
muito mais especialmente delas mesmas
baumann disse que há dois valores
fundamentais para uma vida feliz
um é a segurança
o outro é a liberdade para bauma não
seria possível uma vida feliz na
ausência de qualquer um dos dois
liberdade sem segurança é caos
seguranças em liberdade
a escravidão
a bela velhice depende tanto da sensação
de segurança quanto da conquista da
liberdade
como me disse uma pesquisada de 75 anos
ela dizendo não gosto quando dizem que a
velhice a melhor idade a prioridade não
é melhor nem pior
é simplesmente diferente com saúde
dinheiro e bons amigos dá pra ser feliz
em todas as fases da vida
por que não agora hoje eu posso ser eu
mesmo pela primeira vez na vida
eu sou livre para ser a criança que eu
sempre fui continua sendo posso rir
brincar e sonhar muito mais
então eu quero contar um sonho pra vocês
eu tive recentemente no sonho e eu dizia
pra todos os meus alunos da ufrj
a única categoria social que todo mundo
é velho somos classificados como homem
como mulher negra
o branco homo ou heterossexual mais
velho todo mundo é hoje ou amanhã
o jovem de hoje é o velho de amanhã
por isso como nos movimentos libertários
do século passado do tipo black is
beautiful deveriam vestir uma camiseta
com os dizeres eu também sou velho e
velho é lindo
no sonho fomos em passeatas para a copa
pra copacabana todos juntos os velhos de
hoje os velhos de amanhã
vestindo camiseta e carregando cartazes
com os dizeres eu também sou velho e
velho é lindo
na manifestação inspirada e martin
luther king
eu fiz um discurso apaixonado
eu tenho um sonho
eu tenho um sonho que um dia o velho
será considerado lindo e queremos viver
em uma nação em que as pessoas não serão
julgadas pelas rugas da sua pele e sim
pela beleza do seu caráter
somos livres enfim acordei de madrugada
repetindo alegremente a frase somos
livres enfim estou à vontade pra
copacabana me manifestar gritando eu
também sou zaga e velha é linda
é assim que eu quero terminar dizendo a
todos vocês
os velhos de hoje e os velhos de amanhã
que eu também sou velha e velha linda
somos livres enfim
[Aplausos]
[Música]